in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Jim and
Peggy are with us Peggy mainly hi Peggy
how are you hi how are you better than I
deserve
it's good to have you know where do you
live Tallahassee Florida cool and you're
here with your three sons
yes max Quinn and Josh okay and Jim's
your husband yes he didn't make the trip
no he couldn't but your hair kind of on
a company trip anyway of sorts me
because several folks in your company
went through our smart dollar product
learning how to get out of debt and so
forth right very cool cool so you're
getting ready to do a debt free scream
yes how much debt have you paid off
forty-seven thousand all right very cool
I love it and how long did that take ten
months making what kind of money
household income over a little bit over
a hundred thousand excellent very cool
so you work for a company called muni
code and what do you do at muni code I'm
an illegal editor okay
very cool and what does your husband do
he is a director of communications okay
cool so what kind of debt was the forty
seven thousand twenty four thousand was
a home equity loan and nine thousand
I'm sorry fourteen thousand was the van
and a nine thousand was a credit card
okay all right
excellent very cool so tell me your
story what happened ten months ago that
puts you guys on this journey well I
guess before the smart dollar started in
April of last year and like two months
before that we were coming up short
paying bills okay so your company
decided to teach this class yeah and so
we've been struggling before that and my
husband had some medical issues and so
he changed careers so that lowered our
salary and so it just kind of snowballed
from there and then when the president
of the company started that smart dollar
I was just like overwhelmed because I
was like how did he know that I needed
that so Wow perfect timing then yes yeah
so when your employer decides to teach a
class like this it's very helpful is
what you're saying yes
in this case it was like perfect timing
very cool so tell me what happened what
was the process you all went through to
pay off $47,000 what do you call the
secrets to getting out of debt the
biggest thing is we sold my husband's
car which was paid off actually when we
started smart dollar but it was a Toyota
Tacoma and obviously I think people like
this car that was in demand so we were
able to sell that what did I mean I
think we sold out for 16,000 okay and
then we bought a Honda a small car for
him and then the balance is what we
applied to the debt and then other than
that you roll up your sleeves in a time
no actually we sold a whole life
insurance cashed out that good late we
were stupid and we you know that so okay
so you got good term insurance in place
yes good okay and how much came out of
the whole life policy um I guess 11,000
okay all right very good
and then the rest of it was cash flowed
out of the budget right so by October
that's when we were just like chipping
away at it and that was actually the
hardest part yeah just I wanted to just
go full and just take everything and put
it towards that but we also had to plan
for certain things we travel for swim
meets and we bought a car for Quinn
you know just a used car for him too but
we wanted to budget that in as well okay
she did all of that and paid off this
debt yeah yeah way to go so are you guys
on a good solid written plan that the
two of you are working together yes we
we use that every dollar yeah do you
think you'll stay with it oh definitely
okay definitely very cool there's no
turning back now very cool and so what's
your leaders name that your company that
started this for you guys this uh Eric
grant okay so kudos to Eric then huh yes
all right well very cool I'm proud of
you Peggy very good yeah Jim's behalf
we'll let the three guys Quinn Josh and
Max yellow on behalf of their dad along
with mom very good stuff Jim and Peggy
from Tallahassee Florida forty-seven
thousand dollars paid off in ten months
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream well yes count it down three
three two one
very good hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of Wall Street
you're not a victim of capitalism you're
not a victim of wealth inequality you're
not a victim of racism you're not a
victim